[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview our first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive so it's time
to see what's making the headlines uh
tonight we're expecting the daily mail's
consultant editor andrew pierce any
minute having a few problems with his
line at the moment oh and there he is
behind me there we are he's there he's
there you're on you're on telly andrew
just to warn you also the daily mirrors
associate editor kevin mcguire good to
see both of you um and i'm pleased to
see you anna i think
that goes on
is it okay
still
turned off the power
how about i go i'll go through the front
pages shall i and i'm sure we'll get
andrew
by the end of those so what's on the
front pages of them the metro suggests
the chancellor hasn't taken account of
inflation lower living standards and
higher tax burdens in his spring
statement their headline no heat to eat
the telegraph quotes a critique of the
statement from the office for budget
responsibility which says the country
faces the biggest fall in living
standards on record
the eye has a similar headline and a
striking graph to go with it
normally a staunch supporter of the
tories the express is highly critical
referencing forgotten millions asking
what about us
the guardian accuses the chancellor of
squeezing the poorest and the star is
pretty brunt blunt calling it the up
yours mini budget
and so is the mirror thanks for nothing
the headline there
the financial times says rishi sunak has
banked a 50 billion pound windfall he
could have spent to allow him to cut
taxes before the next general election
as the mail puts it it's now time to
slash taxes even further in the face of
a record squeeze on incomes
and a reminder that by scanning the qr
code that you can see on screen during
the program you can check out all those
front pages of tomorrow's papers for
yourself while you watch us
and so i'm joined by andrew pearce and
kevin maguire good to see you both sorry
we've had a few problems uh
getting through to you there andrew but
nice to see that you can obviously hear
us now
let's dive straight in shall we
all the headlines devoted to the spring
statement today
none of them terribly kind to the
chancellor
on the face of it andrew i don't know
what you think front page of the
telegraph the one you picked out first
uh the biggest fall in living standards
on record they say and that comes from
the government's own financial watchdog
yeah look they won't be very happy in
number 10 about these front pages our
front page in the mail isn't
particularly positive either the express
which has been probably the most loyal
paper of them all is very critical uh
look my news
the fact is he's he he moved further
than we thought in some ways on national
insurance because he's raised the
threshold to 12 750 pounds so that's
going to be an extra 330 pounds for
people that's that's very important but
that's going to be dwarfed by the rise
in fuel bills uh the 5p off um
off fuel duty well he banged on about
it's the biggest cut for 20 years or the
first cup for 20 years but it's pathetic
because
petrol prices went to i think 9p in the
last fortnight so it's he's he's not
done enough and i think the ft has got
it right he's banked a lot of the money
he could have spent today announced
today and i think he's storing it up for
october when we get the second rise in
fuel when the when the uh fuel uh
ceiling is lifted for a second time and
we could really be in big big trouble
with our fuel bills
in november he's going to throw a lot
more money at it but that's not much
consolation to families who are
struggling right now uh so
he's moved quite well he moved further
on the thresholds than i thought but
actually my newspaper was campaigning
for him to get rid of the national
insurance rise altogether and actually
he's made it quite a complicated or
spring statement actually if he just
postponed the entire rise in national
insurance it would have been a lot
easier for everybody well you mentioned
the financial times there and as you say
kevin he did have more money than he
could have spent didn't he because
higher than expected growth meant better
than expected tax receipt so he has got
tens of billions that he could have
spent but does it make sense to wait to
the autumn we're expecting energy prices
to keep on rising he's got to keep
something back hasn't he to help people
out then when that bites
i know it makes no sense if you're a
struggling family now and you're having
to make terrible choices over heat and
eating and your spending because you're
being squeezed you want the help now not
for a political game by a chancellor who
wants to wait for his own
calculation so if he's been clever he's
only been clever in a very party
political way and he could well get a
kicking for that from voters because
they will suffer in the
in the meantime you know they're going
to get all the pain he hopes to have
some political gain i'm not sure you'll
get it that way
because he did have the money to give
greater help and i've never seen a set
of
newspaper from pages that have been so
negative at a conservative budget since
uh they returned to power in in 2010
because of the daily telegraph the daily
tory graph it's been boris johnson's
cheerleader as andrew said the daily
express has been the staunchest uh ally
and supporter
of the the conservatives in power and
even even that is critical so
if you're the chancellor you think
you've been clever you look at those
from pages uh tonight you're not being
clever at all
you've just managed to alienate
everybody now of course the mirror and
the guardian were always going to be
more critical but he hasn't got the
telegraph on this side he hasn't got the
express on his side he hasn't got
andrew's
paper the mail on his side so all those
messages are very very negative for him
well yes and let's look at the express
the forgotten millions say what about us
i mean is the real problem here that the
really the the lowest the poorest
amongst us those on universal credit
because that's due to go up by around
three percent but we've heard today
really high inflation figures uh for the
last month and then it's inflation looks
like it's gonna be more like eight
percent isn't it andrew is that where
the biggest misses in your view
well i think i think so and also
pensioners uh the uh pension the pension
rise is going to be nothing like the
rate of inflation which is
heading for seven percent already could
be eight could be nine percent so but
people on um benefits have got no
upgrade at all here um they they their
chance went on about some complicated
system to the tapering system of
universal credit which will help some
and of course people um won't be paying
any tax or national insurance until
they're earning 12
750 pounds but if you are on benefits
you are going to be struggling a lot
more now the message of the clear
message here i think from the tory
chancellor is get a job uh not always so
straightforward and easy for people but
there are a million vacancies in the
system and that clearly seems to be the
underlying message if you have a job
you'll be a lot better off and we want
to get you off benefits so they make and
they're making it much less attractive
to be on benefits which i often would
say that's the right way you want to get
people back into work but some people
are going to really really struggle with
these fuel bills food bills soaring in
price we know the problem with ukraine
and the
the wheat that's coming out of ukraine
is massively increased in price that's
going to impact on food bills and that's
going to hurt people at the lowest end
of the income scale some people on
benefits who simply can't work because
not everybody can
and while you come back at that kevin
let's look at your front page of your
paper um the mirror thanks for nothing
is the headline there and andrew
mentioned a few things there talking
about the pandemic talking about the war
in ukraine they've been unprecedented
pressures on the chancellor and the need
for
a huge amount of spending to bail us out
of crises but you just can't keep
spending forever can you yeah covered
last year
ukraine this year and next year a big
boy with a stick who runs away oh look
she's richie sudak's got a face up to
his responsibilities and what's
happening in the economy he can't just
keep blaming other people when as you've
just pointed out the ft you're recording
he had a lot of money to spend but he's
decided not to not to go with it yet
he's gonna let people suffer because he
wants to play his political games uh
later on so yes you can keep
spending up to some extent uh anna and
uh as you as you know we're finding
money for the war in ukraine we found
money for covert uh and he can find
money for projects he wants now so he
will get he will get deservedly a lot of
stick over this i think the uh the
office for budget responsibility say
he's returning about one pound in every
six
extra he's taken in tax over the last
two years he is a tax raising chancellor
he keeps saying oh my okay aim is to be
low tax he is raised tax to record
romance as the telegraph points out the
tax burden is back to levels not seen
since clement atlee was prime minister
after the second world war
i'm cutting only because we've not got
much time and i just want to talk about
the daily mail's front page your paper
andrew now slash taxes even further so
if the tax burden is high now
yes there's obviously an awful lot of
tory mps will want to see
taxes cut but what do you make of him
announcing an income tax cut in 2024 i
mean that's that's just that's a
political move isn't it
it is but what he's trying to show is
that the tory party are back on the road
towards cutting taxes again because
they don't want to be out maneuvered by
labour by labor beginning to say this is
the tories of the high tax party that's
a disastrous place for the toys to be
they've been the party of late taxation
since mrs thatcher nigel lawson he's got
that portrait of nigel lawson in his
office in the treasury nigel lawson was
the chance to cut tax from 60p to 40p
the top rate attack so this is what he's
trying to do to say yes i am on your
side i am cutting your taxes but he
might cut it next year buy a penny in
the pound it might be the year after
it's okay quite clever politics because
he's basically saying to labor will you
vote down the increase go down the cut
i'm going to cut both of you off i'm
going to be rude to both of you i'm
afraid at least i'm equal we are going
to take we're going to take a break uh
right now do you say with us though
coming up the u.s pledges to pursue
russia for war crimes but would it
succeed i'm going to talk about that in
a moment
[Music]
you're watching the press preview with
me tonight andrew pearce and kevin
mcguire so welcome back to youtube kevin
we're turning to the guardian's second
story on their front page us pledges to
pursue russia for war crimes this is joe
biden touched down in brussels tonight
yeah for nato's summit and uh anthony
blinken the
secretary of state the foreign secretary
effect of the us is saying they will
pursue the russians and so they should
as we watch the pounding of uh ukrainian
cities and particularly mario paul these
are clear war crimes but i wonder how
they're going to pursue it because the
us itself doesn't recognize the
jurisdiction of the international
criminal court in the hague it's never
joined it
partly i suspect because the us has been
a rogue state in some ways itself in uh
in the past so i think it's quite right
the denunciations and condemnations of
putin and the forces of war crimes but
quite how a country like the us
will be able to
forward that prosecution i'm not sure
yeah is that true it is an interesting
one isn't it andrew and and in the
meantime what do you make of the fact
that joe biden is arriving now in europe
do you think that he could have gone
sooner
are you surprised that he's he's
arriving there now
well um
i don't know i suppose
he's got to go at some point um there's
a big nato meeting so good time to do it
um i just don't think he's
i just i just might i just have a heavy
heart when i hear biden speaking i mean
kevin's quite right i mean he's talking
about international war crimes well
that's going to have to take place in
the hague and i don't think the united
states can be anything to do with it
britain's already been involved in the
process as of the european union
countries so um i think biden's just
trying to get in on the action but um
how does how can a united states get do
it because um they don't recognize that
court and that's where he has to go he's
gonna have to go to the hague well yeah
i mean this is a subject that we're
gonna revisit um in just a moment uh
we're also gonna talk about ash bharti's
surprise retirement haven't got time to
talk about that now but lots of us to
get our teeth into at 11. kevin and
andrew for the moment thanks very much
indeed and we'll see you again very
shortly